so sleep paralysis is something that's
actually very common many people have it
I've had it myself and what happens is
when you're in that REM stage of sleep
your body your brain is very active
you're dreaming the most during that
stage your mind your eyes are moving
there's a lot that's going on it's like
fireworks going on in your brain now
what happens in the rest of your body
and this is an evolutionary function is
that your body has muscle atonia meaning
your muscles are basically turned off
they can't work so your brain is active
your muscles can't work now for what
happens in sleep paralysis is that some
patients and will notice this earlier in
the morning because you're having more
REM sleep then we'll wake up in the
middle of REM sleep so I know myself I
woke up once in the middle of REM sleep
and I couldn't move my muscles and it
was very scary and it's scary for anyone
who has it because your mind is very
active your eyes are active but nothing
else is moving so you have to give
yourself a little while you'll come out
of the REM state your muscles awaken
it's fine it's a totally normal thing to
have now it can be indicative sometimes
of other sleep disorders so we'll see a
lot in narcolepsy so some patients will
report that they have sleep paralysis if
we see sleep paralysis alone and nothing
else we don't really think all that much
of it but if we see other symptoms then
it might be a red flag for something
else that's going on
so in REM behavior disorder RBD it's a
newer diagnosis I'd say probably about
the past ten to fifteen years we're
really recognizing it more and more
patients will come to our practice then
they'll say I'm I'm waking up in the
morning and right I have bruises on my
arms my fists are bloody or they're say
you know I my house was a mess I found
things all over the place generally that
can be sleepwalking but sleepwalking
tends to not be as violent and that's
earlier in the night when you're in the
deeper stages of sleep in RBD it tends
to be a bit more violent a bit more
aggressive so when you're in REM sleep
your muscles supposed to be have a tone
yet and no known function for them but
for some patients their muscles don't
turn off so if they're having a
nightmare a very vivid dream they'll
actually act out essentially their dream
in their sleep during REM sleep so
that's why we'll start to see it we'll
see patients come in with bruises their
beds a mess they might fall out of bed
things like that so it can be for some
patients a very violent problem that we
actually need to treat and aggressively
yeah there's some that are REM behavior
disorder we'll see for some court
documented cases you know and they
really need to have a thorough
evaluation with a sleep specialist you
can't just say oh I was while I was
sleeping
there's confusional arousal so there are
states and deeper sleep that can happen
where people will go and they'll
disappear or they'll they'll take on
some other persona there or commit some
crime but it's all when they're in a
very deep stage of sleep so you really
need to have a very thorough evaluation
but yes there is there's a line of work
of people who work with people have been
charged for crimes and will actually do
sleep disorder analyses with them